the village of trevone lies 30
kilometers from the front line in
ukraine's donbass region
in an oasis of tranquility in the middle
of a crisis zone
jeff henrichenko has lived here for
eight years
but the cottage is poorly insulated and
cold
after all this was supposed to be
temporary
the lachenko's home is elsewhere in
occupied territory
jeffen
was a protestant pastor
when pro-russian separatists appeared he
did not hide his pro-ukrainian views
in his sermons he often said that he
would gladly give a free ticket to
russia to anyone who didn't support
ukraine
you could be shot for saying things like
that at the time
they could take your life toss you into
a basement somewhere those were terrible
times
we weren't prepared and could hardly
believe what was happening
the lachenkos got the warning in time
they were able to flee and have been
living here in chivonne ever since
the village is situated between crimea
and the occupied donbass region
in an area some expect to be the first
target of any russian invasion
but after what we experienced there's no
escaping the subject of war the entire
country is at risk of attack not just
here
we head towards the front line
there are checkpoints on every road in
the area
and the closer we get to the demarcation
line with the separatist forces the more
frequent they become
a ceasefire has been in place since
2015.
the front line has not shifted but the
fighting continues
la nina is one of the last villages on
ukrainian controlled territory
soldiers are everywhere but life goes on
locals have been following the build-up
of russian troops on the border very
closely
the situation is terrifying
the ukrainian military's foremost
position is on the outskirts of the
village just in front of the
demilitarized zone
a footbridge leads to no man's land
it's off limits to soldiers and
reporters
but people cross it every day the
villagers of starmarvka
which lies right between the two fronts
every day svetlana a teacher crosses
over to her
she doesn't want to reveal her real name
for people here maintaining good
relations with both sides is key to
survival a village is often been caught
in the crossfire
i have a job so i go to school every day
living here is hard dangerous even very
dangerous
but stopping now and just running away
no i can't do that i just can't
there aren't any children at the school
right now
but that's not due to the fighting but
because of coronavirus measures
the children are doing remote learning
the teachers come to school for its
better internet connection
the school is just 500 meters from the
military post
we go to work every day and the children
normally go to school
but we never know what's going to happen
in five or ten minutes or the next night
we're always nervous always scared
[Music]
in giovonne jeffen leschenko has decided
to build a new bigger and better
insulated house
he wants to live there with his children
and grandchildren
the longer the conflict drags on
the less likely the family will ever go
home
lots of people can't decide what to do
even though russian troops might one day
stand on his doorstep here too
he doesn't believe he'll have to flee
again
[Music]
it's not 2014 anymore
people won't just throw their hands in
the air and let the attackers walk right
in this time
today people here are ready to defend
their land
eight years into the conflict the people
here have no choice but to live with
this situation
[Applause]
[Music]